as we all know writing something coming
up with something is starting from
scratch every time and you're
Reinventing the wheel every time so
you know it's just a question of like
a lot of times if I have a thing which
and I've got all these things going
right now for example that I'm
developing and hopefully can start
shooting and
but you have to start from scratch every
time so you're like okay what's another
idea that feels real to me that feels
true that is funny and that could sell
and then you're just starting from a
blank page every time so it's it's never
easy how many how many projects do you
have just in what you're working on
right now
I kind of at the moment it's in
different phases I have I guess like
maybe three features and maybe like five
TV things but that's I think that's a
lot of things but it's too it's a it's
at it's a combination for me honestly of
both too much and not enough like
because that I don't like to be spread
thin I'm not happy when I'm working on
even more than one project I'm most
happy when I'm fully and things out
invested and I'm in prep or shooting or
posts where I'm like really really
deeply and I can't even think about
anything else that's when I'm happiest
in my work yeah um but in a phase where
you're developing pitching writing you
know and you sort of have to juggle
things because you just don't know
what's going to take flight that's less
fun for me
um but necessary I'll never push
something forward if I don't think all
that is a home run right and sometimes
people just say oh people don't want a
movie like that anymore
oh that movie's too weird yeah we just
put out a weird movie and uh we don't
think people like weird movies and
suddenly you're like wait I got four of
these oh [__] that are kind of eccentric
and they're not you know a generic type
of movie right but it definitely does
happen and you have to spin the plates
because I remember early in my career I
spent like three or four years on one
script because I thought that's what you
do what script was that I wrote a script
with Owen Wilson
and it was right after bottle rocket
which I love and uh the cables guy I
love bottle rocket just genius and we we
wrote this script about a man who got in
a drunk driving accident but wasn't an
alcoholic and his sponsor at AAA where
he was forced to go by the courts was
ripped torn
and it was ripped torn convincing him
that he was an alcoholic even though he
wasn't and this strange friendship
between them
and I worked on it for years and just
right when I was ready to go
it was nope we don't want to do it
and it never happened and it never
happened how often do they never come
back or how often do they come back like
projects that you are they say no we're
not doing this how often because you
hear these things like kickball
dodgeball dodgeball
and it took 12 years and the studio
didn't want to do it they didn't want to
do it and finally after 12 years that
seems like it rarely rarely happens when
something's turned down it hangs in
there and comes back I mean we've had
that a fair amount of time Superbad took
forever I mean super red was floating
around when we were doing Freaks and
Geeks wow and we made it in 2000
six or around six or seven uh and they
had been working on it since they were
like 13 years old I mean this was their
Seth and Evan's dream was was this movie
and everyone said no forever and then
other movies started succeeding like
Talladega Nights and things that I was
working on and then people said what
what else do you have and so we had a
trunk of rejected projects
but I think and you always hear this
they always say like you could be like I
love this right I've done this before
where I I wrote something and I'm like
this has to sell this is it this is
genius and that's all I'm focused on but
if that doesn't sell right which most
the time it doesn't right what else do I
have going on so that's why you have to
have a lot of things like you have going
so that when the one hits hopefully boom
I'm going to that right now yeah it's
it's that balance has been a constant
question or challenge for me because
there's also that fantasy I have of I
think of an idea I spend every ounce of
me to get that thing done get it done
put it out there take a break and then
do that again like that would be my
fantasy life if I could pull that off
but I've never been realistically as you
said you have to have a million irons in
the fire because you know they're all
gonna yeah everything's half the ninety
percent of things aren't not going to
come to fruition so it's it's an
interesting
challenge it is